okay so let's continue our analysis and
discussion of the firing de-facto firing
the forced resignation of Jeff Sessions
and the bringing in of Matthew Whitaker
who is unconstitutionally inserted by
Donald Trump and causing all sorts of
chaos involving both left-wing and
right-wing legal scholars saying you
can't do this you simply cannot do this
many many problems with Matthew Whitaker
he's in the tank on Russia there's been
this op IDI that he wrote which now has
been scrutinized he wrote it on CNN
saying that the molar probe is wrong and
it's bad and that he would end it by
starving it of funds the appointment
itself unconstitutional as I said and we
now have learned that back in 2014 he
actually ran for the Republican Iowa
u.s. senator from Iowa Republican
nomination back in 2014 and Matthew
Whittaker said that judges without a New
Testament biblical view of justice
shouldn't serve on the federal bench and
he even went as far as to suggest that
he'd try to prevent non-christian judges
from being appointed to the bench if he
got a chance and he is very close to
getting that chance right now back when
he was running for that Republican
nomination in Iowa he attended a forum
that was hosted by the religious right
group the family leader and a lot of
crazy ideas as you can probably imagine
were floated at that forum including
using god-given natural law to decide
who would make good judges Whitaker went
even beyond that prepare yourself to be
disgusted during this forum Matthew
Whitaker said while I agree that I want
to understand their judicial philosophy
and whether they understand natural law
and natural rights and then the founding
documents and how they fit together
I don't think that gets us far enough
because natural law often times is used
from the eye of the beholder what I'd
like to see is things like their
worldview are they
people of faith do they have a biblical
view of Justice I think that is very
important and the moderator interjected
Levitical or New Testament this is code
for are Jews allowed Levitical biblical
code would would include Jews because
it's Old Testament New Testament would
also exclude Jews and Matthew Whittaker
said I'm a New Testament and what I know
is as long as they have that New
Testament worldview that they'll be a
good judge later in this same forum he
also mentioned he would be extra
concerned about atheists being judges
saying quote if they have a secular
worldview then I'm going to be very
concerned about how they judge this is
against the Constitution of the United
States which says no religious test
shall ever be required as a
qualification to any office or public
trust under the United States this is
against the stated mission of the
Justice Department this is against
everything that the United States is
supposed to be and this is what the top
law enforcer of the United States
believes this is his version this is a
Christian version of Sharia law and we
find so often Pat that it's okay for
there to be no separation of church and
state as long as it's their religion but
as soon as someone wants to swear on a
Koran or doesn't believe in God they
should not be allowed and this is so
dangerous and it just has to be stopped
I don't know how else to say it Pat
right Matt what occur could be more
backwards and bigoted than even the last
Attorney General Jeff Sessions even
though sessions is someone who said that
he thinks the ACLU and the n-double-a-cp
are unamerican and that they tried to
force civil rights down our throats
we've mentioned over and over the
comments about how he used to like the
KKK before they started smoking pot all
that stuff is bad Whitaker could end up
topping that this is how we return to
the Dark Ages quite frankly and why the
developed world is laughing at us which
we're going to talk about in the next in
the next show that's that's a piece I'm
working on
this stuff is more in line with what
happens in the countries that many
Americans claim we are better than a lot
of the countries where you have people
on the right saying we can't allow them
to come here because we are just so
superior to them in every way this is
what they say not what I say this is the
type of stuff that goes on in those
countries and in addition a company that
Whitaker was involved with as an adviser
is under FBI investigation there they're
putting in charge of the FBI a guy who
has been advising a company that is
being investigated by the FBI the
company is called world Patent marketing
Whitaker was on the advisory board they
are under potential criminal
investigation by the FBI right now this
must be stopped this absolutely has to
be stopped and you know that this is
starting to get to the White House and
to Donald Trump because Trump is now
going into talking point komuz denying
he even knows Matthew Whitaker and those
are the clips I want to get to next I am
thrilled to tell you that today's
episode is sponsored in part by Blink
accom slash Pakman blinka is a really
unique service for your phone tablet and
web browser and it is incredibly useful
for people like me who love books and
learning but are busy blinka stakes the
best and most popular non-fiction books
and condenses them into 15-minute
audiobooks I'm sure that if you're like
me you have a very long list of books
that you've been meaning to read you
only have so many hours in the day and
that's why blink astiz so amazing they
take the most important information the
themes the insights from each book and
they distill it into a 15 minute audio
book that you can listen to in one
sitting I've listened to a ton of books
on blankets our audience can get a seven
day free trial by going to blink accom
slash Pakman if you're watching on
youtube i've put a link in the
description i have listened to blinka
spokes about economics about political
science about history about science so
many in
doing things and after the free trial if
you like it you can continue enjoying
thousands of condensed audiobooks for
about 5 bucks a month go to blink accom
slash Pakman that's bli n ki st.com /pa
k ma n